ESPN senior writer author Bella check
the making of the greatest football
coach of old-time ease ian o'connor
and he joins us now and good morning ian
how are you hi Dan how are you I'm doing
well what kind of feedback have you
gotten from the New England area on the
book there well zero from the Patriots
from the New England area a lot of
people read the excerpts on espn.com and
obviously when you excerpt a book some
of the edgier juicier Nuggets are pulled
out and maybe something gets lost in
translation as it relates to the core
purpose of the book so it's focused on
the Brady Belichick relationship an
anonymous assistance quote about Brady
and the idea that the system could
elevate the top 15 quarterbacks in the
league and and really it's a 455 page
two hundred and thirteen thousand word
examination of bills life and I think
until people actually read the book they
won't really understand maybe the true
spirit of it so I hope that does happen
obviously and thank you for giving me
the opportunity did you get any
cooperation from Belichick or get close
to any cooperation no absolutely not I
kind of knew Dan going in that that
probably would happen and tried to pitch
around it as best I could that's why I
talked to 350 people and he did ask some
people not to speak with me which is his
right he certainly doesn't owe me
anything and there's a little
disappointing but again he has every
right to do that and so no I I did sit
down with his chief of staff up there
bears Najarian we had lunch and I
explained why I was doing the project
and I wanted to get in front of Bill to
at least explain the hows and whys and
that didn't happen I did ultimately at
the end of the process contact Bill
directly via email and said as I'm
winding this down and speaking to a
hundred hundreds of people and my only
agenda is trying to get this right I'd
love to get in front of you and he did
respond to that very cordially it was
brief painfully brief but he just said
thanks for the invitation but I'm very
busy and I think I'll take a pass so
that's where we are but I think I still
painted a full human portrait of the man
and I guess ultimately the the reader
will be the judge of that if you had one
question that you knew he was gonna
answer what would it be you know the
first thing that's a very good question
first thing that pops in my mind when
you asked that was Spygate
because as I looked at it and I dug into
that case and found some new details
about it I really don't think and I
don't know if I thought this in 2007
when the case broke I don't think it was
really that big of an advantage so if
Eric Mangini got word to you and mangini
of course was the head coach of the Jets
at the time that don't do this in our
house or we're gonna have to act and he
did it anyway I'm just surprised that he
would do it because the risk was too
great they got caught it changed the way
America outside of New England anyway
looked at his program and his dynasty
and I just don't think there was enough
of an advantage there to take that risk
when you knew ahead of time that the
Jets were going to pounce if you did it
so I just would like to ask that
question like you're so good at what you
do your team that was the best team you
ever had even though they didn't win the
championship but they were 18 to know
why did you take that risk I just didn't
understand that so that's the first
question that top popped in my head when
you asked that and I think I would love
to hear his answer to that because I
really don't believe in retrospect and
I've asked a lot of people around the
league I've gotten all kinds of opinions
on on that that they needed to do that
that and that it gave them that big of
an advantage also you have situations
controversies that we'll have a team
unravel you've got a team in Pittsburgh
it feels like that they unravel when
there's ever controversy did you have
anybody tell you that this almost
emboldened them it brought them closer
together that they realized the Patriots
at an early age in this dynasty it's us
against the world here and I don't know
if Belichick played to that or Brady
played to that and made it even bigger
well I think that in the locker room the
players felt that they wanted to prove
to the world that you are now
questioning our authenticity and and
everything that we've ever done here and
we were going to prove to you that it's
not about that at all and they did they
won after a spy gate broke they won 70
straight games and they should have won
the Superbowl and they had 17 things in
that game work against them but that is
the best football team I've ever seen
and it's ironic that's one team that
didn't win a title and Bill's had five
of those championship teams but after
deflategate there's no question that
they were inspired to win it all and
they did and then Brady when he came
back in after the suspension I talked to
a couple of his close friends including
Aaron Shea his former teammate at
Michigan he said on the record he goes
Tom is really angry about this and
they've ticked him off to the nth degree
and he's going to come back even better
and I know Belichick has shot down the
notion that any of his players including
Brady could be elevated any higher or
inspired anymore than they already were
but Brady's a human being and I do think
that took him to a new level and the one
thing about Bill with those two cases
you can see he's a great crisis manager
and I don't think he gets enough credit
for that even even last year you had the
whole his friendship with the president
then he had protesting players on the
other side he'd managed that that was a
very delicate situation for him and
there was almost this unspoken agreement
between Belichick and his players
I'm gonna give you the freedom to
express yourselves and how you feel
about these social issues but understand
that this is not going to ruin our
season and divide our team and it didn't
they got to the Super Bowl and then
obviously they lost he and O'Connor ESPN
senior writer authored the book is
Belichick the making in the greatest
football coach of all time I love the
book I did have a problem with that
title of the greatest football coach of
all time I don't know if Belichick is I
think Paul Browns the greatest football
coach of all time because what he'd you
know he was in it and I know it's
generational here but Belichick is great
we know that I just thought Paul Brown I
still look at is somebody who was unique
who changed the game let me give you
you're right about that he's the
greatest innovator certainly of all time
he's basically he's the founding father
of everything and hotter an NFL right
but let me say this if you look at Dan
at his final 15 years of coaching he did
not win one postseason game now they
weren't playing as many postseason games
they weren't as many teams in the
playoffs I understand that but if you
really look at
his he had some lean years in there on
the end and you know Belichick obviously
had lean years in Cleveland and and his
first year in New England but that's a
long stretch 15 years without winning
one postseason game to finish your
career so Vince Lombardi to me is the
ultimate standard that I think Belichick
surpassed I went to the high school or
Vince Lombardi coached and so to get
over that hump for me personally they're
all the priests and nuns at my high
school would be really mad at me for
saying that that to me was the standard
and I do think Belichick surpassed that
I had a couple of things because you do
talk about some things that I have had
strong opinions on the Belichick love
affair with Jimmy Garoppolo I think that
there was a tug of war there that
Belichick wanted to keep him and would
have been fine if Tom walked the
relationship between Brady and mr. Kraft
after deflategate and wait where are you
do you have my back
that Belichick was suspicious of Brady
with deflategate like there's just so
much there and it's still amazing that
they kept it as much as they could in
house and still survived and thrived at
that I mean all of those stories are
amazing I think you're right and I know
you're a big basketball guy and and your
relationship the professional
relationship you had with Michael Jordan
the Jordan Bulls I mean Jordan and Phil
Jackson as you know they couldn't stand
Jerry Krause and he put the whole thing
together they weren't even speaking most
of the time and yet they won six
championships the Steinbrenner Yankees
had all kinds of internal conflict and
turmoil and they won so it's not the
first time we've seen that they have
done a masterful job behind the scenes
of keeping it all behind closed doors
until last year where you had some very
good Boston reporters report on the
tension the escalating tension between
Brady and Belichick a lot of it's
centered around Garoppolo and Alex
Guerrero seth wickersham of ESPN with
his great piece and and it's the first
time it's amazing it took 18 years for
it to come into public view and i guess
it's a testament to them and their
ability to keep things sealed off but
the relationship survived barely because
tom as of and i report this in the book
late march was still thinking of walking
away rather than playing for his head
coach again
and I think they're okay now I think
it's a functioning relationship I do
think they have one more ring left in
them it might not be this year but I
think they're okay it's always been a
transactional relationship and that's
what it is right now
but that's you bring me to another point
with their relationship I honestly
thought if the Patriots won the Super
Bowl against the Eagles that Brady would
have walked away that I think it's not I
think it's just I don't love this
because I have to deal with this with
him and bring Brady loves to practice
you know he's a gym rat like the whole
thing and I I don't know if you felt
that or you got any indication that you
know what if we win I can just walk away
Gisele is you know said it publicly that
she's worried about me and my health and
my kids and I just thought Brady would
have walked away if he won the Super
Bowl well I'll say this then the Super
Bowl week I spoke to a close friend of
Brady's who said that Brady had told him
fairly recently winning three out of
four twice which is something obviously
nobody's ever done would be a great way
to walk away hmm and he meant it so it's
possible he would have done that on the
other hand I talked to Brady on the
phone for about 50 or 55 minutes in the
spring of 2017 and we were talking about
him playing at age 46 and 47 never mind
45 so my feeling is that at least after
the Garoppolo trade it's hook walking
away really off the board I mean how
would the fan base have reacted yeah if
he inspired them to trade Garoppolo his
successor and then he walked away that
that would have been he would have been
the bad guy in that drama yeah but he'd
also be able to stick it to Belichick a
little bit but because I once again and
I don't know how petty he gets but I and
I still go back to you gift-wrap
Garoppolo to the Niners for a
second-round pick and it just felt like
this is Garoppolo
do you think that Brady played a role in
saying it's either me or him as we might
think I don't think he ever said that I
don't think he would ever say that I
don't think Robert Kraft ever said the
words you have to trade Jimmy G I think
Robert Kraft made it very clear to
Belichick that Tom Brady is going to
retire a New England Patriot whether
that's 45 44 47 he's not going anywhere
so Belichick walked away believing that
he had to make that move now why a
second-round pick why not own why not
hold an NFC only auction for Garoppolo
was made the most sense get him out of
the conference but think somebody's
going to give me a first-round pick for
him I think he wanted to place him with
an offensive coach he respected I think
he really likes him personally Garoppolo
he wanted the kid to succeed and also be
good for his legacy Belichick
if he did win a championship or two in
San Francisco with an offensive coach he
believed in so I think all those things
came into play and that's why the trade
happened the way it did this Belichick
care if he's linked not respected but
linked no not publicly because he plays
that character that you see every day at
the podium and that's not who he is I've
talked to many of his friends a lot of
them didn't want to be named in the book
but who wished that he showed some
humanity at the podium because they see
it all the time and so he that's not who
he is so I don't think he cares about
his image you saw the clip the other
night walking into Detroit into the
building two little kids hold out their
hands and when he's working he's at work
don't do that do not stick now they're
kids they don't know but don't stick
your hand out I mean this is the same
guy who has walked past Robert Kraft in
the hallway at Patriot Place and doesn't
say hi it sometimes does even say a word
to the man paying a millions and
millions of dollars but he does that to
everybody so it's just who he is at work
it's not who he is away from the
facility who does who is history kinder
to that you call Bella check the
greatest football coach of all time and
maybe believe Brady's the greatest
quarterback of all time but history is
kinder to which legacy here that's a
good question I think Brady is the
greatest football player of all time so
gym brat my father would kill me for
saying that but Jim Brown he started
making movies at 8:30 so Belichick is
the one who created the culture there
and I think ultimately if McDaniels
takes over afterward and carries it on
and finds another quarterback and wins
more with that system I think maybe
Belichick because of what he created
around Brady
and Brady himself has told me that he
believes he's a I asked him are you
ready to this is in the spring of 17 are
you ready to concede that you are
greater than your idol Joe Montana and
you are the best quarterback of all time
he said no because I believe I'm a
product of the system the people who
have coached me and I played with and I
think a lot of quarterbacks in my shoes
would have accomplished similar things I
don't know if that was just humility or
he believed that to a certain degree
which was I think he did but I think if
I had to give the edge to one of the
other legacy wise I would go with
Belichick but again I'm writing a book
I'm pushing a book about Belichick so
I'm probably the wrong guy to ask that
question right now
do you think Brady feels like if you
could get him both to answer this
Brady feels like he made Bella check or
Bella check feels like he made Brady I
really believe this that they they they
understand they couldn't have done it
without the other
I think Brady understands Belichick was
worth one extra ring to him and I think
Belichick believes Brady was worth one
extra to him in other words you give
Belichick a very good quarterback who's
proven he could win - I think bill would
win three with that player same thing
with Brady and the coat so I think
that's a pretty even deal there I really
do think that they're worth with
somebody who's who's proven to be very
good one extra title and I don't know if
that's how they look at it but that's
how I look at it anyway I'll leave you
with this question the answer that you
got about Belichick where you went oh my
gosh that's gold about Belichick or just
the story itself well to me the the most
profound story in the book it the first
one I told about his father his father
was in the US Navy serving during World
War two and he was on Okinawa he was the
only black officer walked in Samuel
Barnes he was one of the first black
officers in the United States Navy every
white officer in the club walked out
except one Steve Belichick and he'd
befriended the man and Barnes's family
that the Belichick name means a great
deal to them for that reason they were
roommates for short period of time and I
think I think that really shaped Bill I
think he grew up in a household that was
way ahead of its time and race relations
in this country and that
credit to his father his mother and I
think that's why when people wonder how
does Bill really inspire or connect with
the african-american athlete I think
it's because of his father and mother
and the way he was raised in that in
that home and that's one of the reasons
why I really opened the book with that
anecdote Congrats on the book good luck
with it and great to talk to you again
Ian thanks for joining us thank you Dan
appreciate it let's see an O'Connor ESPN
senior writer the book is Belichick the
making of the greatest football coach of
all time for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]